what's going on guys this is rob and i
have this idea i have a theory i know
that like the whole thing with kamala
khan is the most popular thing ever but
bear with me here because i think kamala
khan is going to be more powerful than
carol danvers or at least really really
close to it not only that uh i think i
found the connection or at least i have
an idea on the connection between carol
danvers and kamala khan
and the ten rings of shang qi uh i don't
really know exactly how it is that uh
monica rambo fits into this
but i think it all goes back to the cree
and i think it is pointing in the
direction of the inhumans or the very
least some baseline introduction of
their existence so for the most part we
know about the ten rings we know pretty
much everything about them with the
exception of two things one is their
origin which we'll cover we'll talk
about here and the second is what
there's where they're sending a signal
to uh which is something we've
speculated in the past that has came to
conquer things like that honestly
everybody's just kind of spitballing and
guessing at this point and we already
know what's going on with carol danvers
and all that kind of good stuff so let's
talk about what's going on with the
bracelets of kamala khan now the big
theory going on out there is that
they're likely the quantum bands or the
nega bands which kind of makes sense um
i think the marvel cinematic universe is
actually just merging the two bands
together which i think also makes sense
because functionally the quantum bands
and mega bands are basically the same
thing right they pretty much do the same
thing the big differentiation between
these two things is really how they're
powered more so than how they're used
and so when it comes to these things the
difference between the quantum bands and
the mega bands is that the quantum bands
are powered by the quantum zone now
those of you guys don't know what that
means the quantum zone is kind of like
the wellspring of all energy and
existence in marvel comics at least it
was for a little while marvel has all
kinds of answers as to how it is that
everything came into existence right you
go back and you read the old like roy
thomas stories it's this explanation
that well you know the the one above all
created everything you know and then you
read al ewing's ultimates and as well it
was the first universe that was created
by the one above all and then when the
first universe was destroyed or at least
fractured into an infinite number of
pieces during the celestial holy war
then that gave us the first multiverse
and then if you read jonathan hickman's
secret wars from 2015 well the current
iteration of the multiverse is basically
made up of the energy of the molecule
man owen reese and it was shaped by
franklin richards and then its foreman
function was had basically been
memorized by reed richards over the
course of his life and that's where the
multiverse comes from now there's all
kinds of different answers there right
but in effect the quantum bands
essentially use life force in order to
keep themselves powered and a person who
uses it can manipulate all forms of
energy depending on who's using it they
can make themselves invulnerable there's
a lot of different possibilities there
on the other side the megabands are
actually powered by the negative zone
i.e anti-matter energy but at the end of
the day they all still pretty much do
the same thing so it makes the most
sense that in order to simply
simplify things the marvel cinematic
universe is just like she's got cosmic
bands and like that's it and they can
call them whatever they want to the
quantum bands the mega bands what have
you now here's where things come into
play the energy in terms of as it was
being emanated between uh between the
quantum bands or whatever bands it is
that kamala khan has looks almost
identical to the energy as it was being
emanated by shang chi as well as carol
danvers and the reason why i say that
especially when it comes to the 10 rings
because one thing to remember is that
the bands let off two different types of
colors there was one color that it was
letting off when shane chi's father was
using it then there was a different
color when shang chi was using it
meaning that it can kind of use both
colors as it wants to that was most
likely designed to illustrate the
difference in terms of like their
alignment to good or evil or selfishness
versus altruism or whatever but in
effect you merge those two colors
together emanating from the rings at the
same time it looks almost exactly like
the same power that kamala khan was
showing in the trailer as well as the
power that carol danvers lets off now
carol danvers is sort of a weird piece
here because remember she gained her
powers when the light speed engine had
basically exploded and then just
bombarded her with all kinds of energy
and that engine was powered by the
tesseract so she's kind of a walking
talking space stone more or less but she
is able to do some pretty incredible
things what i think we're looking at
when it comes to the 10 rings in kamala
khan is we're looking at a form of
technology that was previously used by
the cree and then ultimately abandoned
because remember during that
post-credits scene in shanghai that uh
that carol danvers says it's not any
form of technology that i've ever seen
right but she hasn't seen every form of
technology ever and there is room here
to make the argument that the cree
ignored it right the creed just
basically got rid of it a really good
example of this is in fantastic four
number six by jonathan hickman really is
called ff number six by jonathan hickman
but basically what you ended up learning
was essentially the the origin or the
history of the inhuman project right the
idea of the cree is that what they
wanted to do was genetically modify
individuals so they could slip into
other societies the chameleons the
badoons all those different guys and
then basically
create civil war right create social and
political discord to make it easy for
the cree to conquer them what ended up
happening is that when the inhuman
project was in full swing and the
results of the project were presented to
the supreme intelligence because the
supreme intelligence is a in a kind of
amalgamation of all the greatest minds
to ever exist in the kree empire the
religious side of those minds basically
created or at least introduced a kind of
prophecy that somewhere along the line a
midnight king would rise that would lead
to their downfall that midnight king of
course being black bolt of the inhumans
the results of this is that the cree
cast aside the inhuman project they
basically deleted all information and
the supreme intelligence had the accuser
core kill everybody who knew anything
about it like they literally clean
slated it and it was effectively wiped
away now ultimately there were a handful
of the inhuman tribes that succeeded and
that's where you get the war of the four
cities from jonathan hickman's fantastic
four the name is awesome the story is
every bit as awesome as you think it is
there's one point where black bolt has
like five wives it's kind of nuts but
regardless it's not outside the realm of
possibility that at some point along the
line assuming this preschool war has
been going on long enough or for their
own personal curiosity the cree had
discovered the ability to tap into the
quantum realm i have a hard time
believing that hank pym some guy on
earth was the first person in the cosmos
to ever figure out that exists
especially when you're talking about a
race like the cree which by the time
hank pym was any measurable scientist
had long since achieved interstellar
travel they had to have been able to
figure that out somewhere along the line
especially when you talk about how their
their political and religious leader the
supreme intelligence is basically a
super computer like it would have
figured something like that out a while
ago so my thought is the supreme
intelligence learned about the quantum
realm realized it was a source of what's
basically infinite energy and then
started weaponizing it the war between
the cree and the scroll were waged on it
eventually came close to earth or
perhaps it had something to do with the
creation of the inhumans and ultimately
for whatever reason that's not explained
the bracelets that are now being used by
kamala khan and the ten rings that were
found in shanghai
basically ended up on earth why they
ended up staying here perhaps it's one
of those things where that that kind of
energy or that power was being used by
the cree to try to wipe out the inhumans
on earth and in turn the inhumans
somehow managed to succeed we don't
really know right it's one of those
weird things too because when they talk
about the idea of the beacon sending out
a signal then of course it could be
sending a signal to a tilland which
nobody knows about is the inhuman royal
city on earth now there are some major
flaws here right like one how could it
possibly be the sorcerer supreme has no
idea that there is a hidden city on
earth the second is how could uh carol
danvers have no idea that how could
anybody not know that's the case at this
point right like the earth has been
explored about as well as it can be uh
but you can also tie this into like the
x-men theory which is going on right now
that the x-men do exist and that xavier
had basically wiped the world's minds of
the x-men's existence so there is room
to create that kind of argument there
the other part of this though is how do
you tie this in to someone like carol
danvers who somehow has no idea this
technology ever existed we know the
supreme intelligence is seemingly still
around and if that information was wiped
there'd be no reason for her to ask
about it because she would never have a
motivation to she would never even knew
it existed in the first place especially
if it was really more of like an
experiment or project that was being
worked on by the cree and was ultimately
abandoned due to the potential danger of
it or some kind of weird prophecy that
like it would ultimately come to an end
another big problem that you have here
is how do you roll in monaco rambo into
all this right that if carol danvers and
kamala khan and the 10 rings are all
basically a result of cree technology
being used to harness the ability to
alter or use other sources of energy out
there is it one of those where basically
uh you know monica rambo kind of falls
into that same community or that same
group it's just that her power is a
result of one division more so than
anything else i imagine a lot of this
will probably be answered in marvel's
but just looking at the at the the
bracelets of kamala khan they bear a
striking resemblance in terms of like
design and appearance to the ten rings
of the mandarin they don't look exactly
alike but they look pretty similar right
they look like they're cut from the same
cloth so to speak so i think that's a
that's entirely possible here that what
we're looking at is some long abandoned
form of technology that allows
individuals to tap into other sources of
energy right it explains why it is that
the energy let off by the tin rings and
the energy led off by the quantum bands
looks very similar to the energy from
the quantum realm itself in terms of
like how it physically manifests there's
a lot of possibilities here but that's
my thought on this right i wanted to run
this by you guys you know i'll see what
you guys think uh let me know down in
the comments i mean i know i can always
i can always count on you guys to poke
holes in my theories
you guys are nothing if not consistent
when it comes to that
my poor little feelings
but no poke all kinds of holes in this
right i mean i'm really fascinated like
i love the idea of it being the quantum
bands and or the mega bands because that
means we're going full on into like
marvel cosmic right i think it'd be
really kind of weird if kamala khan
basically became the new quasar but it
makes sense if phyla vel could do it so
she you know so could she uh fly lavelle
by the way ridiculously amazing
character but with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this to an end let me
know what you all think down in the
comments section thank you all for
watching and i will catch you all later
peace